the Philippine Navy Sierra Madre
anchored on second Thomas Scholl in the
South China Sea to Mark the Philippines
claim in the disputed region but has
been surrounded by Chinese ships
a recent flight by the Philippine Coast
Guard spotted at least 26 suspected
Chinese Maritime vessels the Chinese
Coast Guard sailing as close as one
nautical mile to the Philippine Vessel
it is the Philippine aircraft hovered
closer they were told to lead by the
Chinese
security
you are entering the territory of China
the voice on the radio said leave
immediately to prevent any
misunderstanding
this follows an incident earlier this
month where the Philippine Coast Guard
says military-grade laser was aimed at
its crew by the Chinese and caused
temporary blindness China denies the
accusation and says the green light was
from a handheld pointer but last weekend
the Philippine Coast Guard revealed
there was another laser-pointing
incident last year there have been years
and years and years of Gray Zone
activity that does not get seen by the
public that's why it's the gray Zone
lighting up the gray Zone takes away the
deniability takes away that opacity
where Gray Zone operators thrive
the Philippine government says it's
stepping up sea patrols to counter what
it considers Chinese incursions and
aggressions it is exploring the
possibility of doing it with allies
including the United States and
Australia whose Deputy Prime Minister
was in Manila last week we did talk
today about the possibility of exploring
joint patrols and and we will continue
that work and we hope that that comes to
fruition soon despite its recent actions
in contested waterways China continues
to advocate for a code of conduct
in Indonesia last week its foreign
minister chin Kang said he intends to
fast-track negotiations with Southeast
Asian countries including the
Philippines
there was hope tension would ease after
Manila and Beijing agreed to establish a
new diplomatic Hotline in January
instead what we've seen in the past few
weeks has been the opposite with both
sides standing firm and vowing not to
give up an inch of their claims in the
south of China Sea
writing below Al Jazeera Manila